أنا فقط لا أعرف أي شيء عن ذلك ، لقد
قرأته هذا الصباح ، لقد كان هناك الكثير من
الأخبار المزيفة التي كانت اجتماعاً جيداً للغاية ، لقد كان في
الواقع اجتماعاً ناجحاً للغاية
ولدي تلك الاجتماعات مع كل
ما لا أعرف شيئاً عنه ، لقد كان اجتماعاً
اجتماع ناجح للغاية تحدثنا فيه عن
إسرائيل وتحدثنا عن خط الأنابيب الذي
تحتكر فيه ألمانيا لروسيا الكثير من المال
لا أعتقد أنه من المناسب تحدثنا
عنه وتحدثنا عن العديد من الموضوعات
ولكن لدي تلك اللقاءات وجهًا لوجه
مع جميع القادة بما في ذلك
رئيس الصين بما في ذلك رئيس وزراء
اليابان آبي ، لدينا تلك الاجتماعات
طوال الوقت ، لم أعمل أبدًا مع
روسيا وأنت تعلم أن الإجابة أفضل
من أي شخص لم أعمل أبدًا مع روسيا ،
ولم أكن أعمل أبدًا مع روسيا
وأعتقد أنه عار.  حتى أنك تطرح
هذا السؤال لأنه خدعة كبيرة جدًا
[موسيقى]